Weil wir haben hier mit Bastian den Open Snip Experten schlechthin.
Genau, das Open Snip ist nämlich auf meinem Mist gewachsen. Aber fangen wir mit 23andMe an. Es gibt 23andMe und andere Firmen, zu denen man wie gesagt seine Speichelprobe hinschickt. Die machen dann die ganze Laborarbeit mit dem langweiligen Puppetieren und am Ende bekommt man sein eigenes Genom oder zumindest einen Teil davon zurück. Den Teil ziehen sie in den Schluss mit an und dann kriegt man, zumindest früher bekam man auch noch eine Auswertung dazu eben, was für Krankheitsrisiken man hat. Ob man ein höhtes Risiko hat für Prostatakrebs, für Brustkrebs, für Alzheimer, Parkinson und noch eine ganze Reihe anderer lustiger Krankheiten und nicht so lustiger Krankheiten. Und das ist momentan eingestellt, diese Gesundheitsauswertung, weil die Food & Drug Administration in den USA 23andMe untersagt hat, diese Tests zu machen, weil sie keine Genehmigung dafür hatten und auch bislang noch nicht wieder haben. Und was sie auch noch machen, ist natürlich eine Auswertung irgendwie. Wir haben gerade schon über Abstammungen geredet im größeren Maßstab, wie ganze Arten miteinander verwandt sind, aber 23andMe schaut sich eben auch an. Haben sie eigentlich in der Datenbank noch andere Leute, die mit einem verwandt sind irgendwie? Also findet man unter Umständen entfernte Verwandte, von denen man vielleicht noch gar nichts wusste, oder wenn die eigene persönliche Historie vielleicht aus, also für US-Amerikaner gerade interessant, woher sind meine Vorfahren eigentlich eingewandert in die USA, dann kann man das mit Wendy Swin zum Beispiel auch untersuchen.
Das heißt, da kann man auch ganz, man schickt einfach zwei oder drei Speichelproben hin und schon hat man einen Vaterschaftstest.
Genau, das ist tatsächlich auch möglicher.
Okay, aber wenn man jetzt gar nichts mehr über sich lernt, sondern nur noch die rohen Daten zurückbekommt, warum wird das dann überhaupt noch gemacht? Ist das dann überhaupt noch interessant?
Das ist immer noch interessant, weil wie gesagt, viele Leute interessieren sich hauptsächlich für den Abstammungsteil. Also vielleicht jetzt nicht für den mehr oder weniger versteckten Vaterschaftstest, sondern tatsächlich umzusehen, vielleicht finde ich ja noch irgendwo der Welt Leute, die mit mir etwas entfernter verwandt sind. Also ich zum Beispiel habe mich über 23andMe testen lassen und mich schreibt eigentlich jeden Monat irgendjemand an und sagt, 23andMe hat vorher gesagt, dass wir irgendwie verwandt sind. Und ich komme aus Kanada oder den USA und naja, wir können ja mal unsere Abstammungsbräume vergleichen. Vielleicht sind wir tatsächlich miteinander verwandt. Das war es bislang nie, aber zumindest...
Wie das heißt, der Algorithmus spuckt irgendwie ein könnte-sein-aus und dann muss man aber noch mal selber drüber rechnen oder wie läuft das?
Genau, der Algorithmus sagt, das ist aufgrund der genetischen Distanz, also wie ähnlich sich diese beiden Genome sind, könnte das ein dritter Cosa von dir sein. Könnte, muss aber nicht.
Und wie genau findet man dann raus, ob es so ist oder nicht?
Indem man tatsächlich einfach mal schaut, wie hießen eigentlich unsere Vorfahren in den letzten drei Generationen und wo kamen die her, wenn man das weiß? Und dann stellt man meistens fest, oh wir sind doch nicht miteinander verwandt.
Ah, okay, also das passiert nicht mehr über das Genom, sondern dann muss die gute alte Detektivarbeit her. Okay, und was ist dann dieses Open Snip?
Open Snip ist eine Plattform, die wir betreiben, wo Leute ihre Ergebnisse von 23andMe veröffentlichen können, in die Public Domain. Also, wenn man seinen eigenen Gendatensatz hat und sagt, bislang hat der nur 23andMe und die dürfen darauf Forschung betreiben, aber ich hätte gerne, dass auch der Rest der Welt Forschung an meinen Daten betreiben kann, dann kann man die bei Open Snip veröffentlichen und schon hat jeder, der einen Internetzugang hat, Zugriff auf diese Daten.
Also, es ist ja so, es gibt von mir relativ wenige Fotos im Internet. Mein Avatar ist ein Bild mit einer Lampe vor meinem Gesicht. Jetzt frage ich mich, ist nicht so sein eigenes Genom, will man das in eine öffentliche Datemang hochladen?
Das kommt auf den Einzelnen an, würde ich sagen. Also tatsächlich für mich war die erste Reaktion als 23andMe mir meine Ergebnisse geschickt hat, noch bevor ich mir mehr oder weniger die Auswertungen, die sie damals noch mitgeliefert haben, angeschaut haben, zu sagen, ich veröffentliche meinen eigenen Datensatz bei GitHub. Warum? Weil wir haben gerade schon viel darüber gehört, dass eben viele Daten verfügbar sind und man als Bioinformatiker oft darauf angewiesen ist, dass Leute ihre Daten frei verfügbar gemacht haben. Und in meiner Arbeit, die ich jetzt während meines Doktors jeden Tag betreibe, das wäre alles überhaupt nicht möglich, wenn Leute ihre Daten nicht veröffentlicht hätten. Sind zwar meistens keine auf irgendwie menschlichen Genomen basierende Daten, sondern auf irgendwelchen anderen Arten. Aber es ist einfach gut, der Community was zurückzugeben. Und das war für mich die Hauptmotivation, zu sagen, hier, andere Leute können mit den Daten bestimmt was Gutes anfangen. Bitte macht das.
Aber wissen die Leute dann auch, dass das quasi dein Genom ist? Oder ist das für die einfach nur das Genom eines Menschen?
Tatsächlich, in meinem Fall ist das mit meinem kompletten Namen verbunden, sämtlichen Social Media Accounts, dass Leute das relativ zweifelsfrei mit mir verbinden können. Allerdings gibt es bei Open Snip keine Verpflichtung dazu, das zu tun. Also Leute können das Ganze zumindest Pseudonym hochladen. Also Leute können sich irgendein lustiges Pseudonym ausdenken, können in der Gefägt die E-Mail-Adresse zur Anwältung verwenden und so weiter. Allerdings muss man natürlich sagen, es sind keine anonymen Daten, denn dieser genetische Datensatz mapfen wir im Zweifelsfall auf genau diese eine Person. Weil selbst wenn man einen Squilling hat, muss man nicht zwingend genau die gleichen Varianten tragen.
Holy, würden die anderen drei das auch machen, ihr Genomal analysieren lassen und dann irgendwie die Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung stellen?
Nö, meine Schwester würde mir wahrscheinlich den Hals umdrehen.
Warum?
Weil sie noch viel größeren Wert auf Privacy legt als ich. Und sie ist halt meine Schwester. Das heißt, die Genvarianten, die ich habe, hat sie zu einem guten Teil halt auch. Das heißt, ich treffe diese Entscheidung nicht nur für mich, sondern auch noch für meine näheren Verwandten.
Ich würde es auch nicht machen. Aber ich würde es vielleicht mir selbst angucken.
Ich denke, anonymisiert würde ich es hochstellen.
Wie viel kann man denn eigentlich über den anderen Menschen lernen? Also wenn ich euch jetzt sage, wenn ich jetzt mit dem Genom ankäme und nicht sagen würde, woher das herkommt, ihr würdet das analysieren, was könnt ihr dann da rauslesen?
Also von meinem eigenen Datensatz kann ich sagen, ich habe den tatsächlich dann auch nicht nur hochgeladen, sondern selbst auch nochmal ausgewertet. Und als kleine Fingerübung, was ich gerne wissen wollte, ist eben tatsächlich mal zu schauen, wie viel kann ich über die Genome meiner beiden Eltern rausfinden darüber. Und ich habe meine Eltern auch tatsächlich gefragt, bevor ich meine Daten veröffentlicht habe, seid ihr eigentlich einverstanden damit? Denn das ist jeweils zur Hälfte auch euer Datensatz. Und wenn ich das veröffentliche, gebe ich viel über euch preis damit. Und die waren beide einverstanden damit. Und bei der Auswertung von meinen eigenen Daten habe ich dann eben rausfinden können, dass meine Daten sind frei verfügbar. Ich kann also problemlos sagen, ich habe ein erhöhtes Risiko für Postdaterkrebs. Und einfach aufgrund der meiner Daten und der frei verfügbaren Auswertung beziehungsweise Assoziationen von Gendaten zu Krankheitsdaten, konnte ich sehen, dass mein Vater das gleiche erhöhte Risiko für Postdaterkrebs trägt und konnte dem dann sagen, hey, pass mal auf, du bist schon irgendwie jetzt 50 plus und solltest eigentlich sowieso vielleicht mal zur Vorsorge gehen, aber mein Genom sagt, du hast das gleiche erhöhte Risiko wie ich, also bitte, bitte geh jetzt tatsächlich mal zum Arzt und sag nicht immer, hm ja, mach ich mal irgendwann.
Was ist das? Ich muss jetzt mal eine ganz uninformatische Frage stellen. Was ist das für ein Gefühl, wenn man über sich selbst und seinen eigenen sterblichen Körper vorhergesagt kriegt, ja, du hast da dieses Ding und das konnte dich möglicherweise mal zur Runde richten?
Ich fand das in gewisser Weise sehr, sehr hilfreich, denn gerade in dem Fall Postertherapeutik gibt es eben Vorsorgeuntersuchungen, wenn man weiß, man ist genetisch vorbelastet dafür, dann nimmt man das Ganze einfach auch mal ein bisschen ernster und geht eben tatsächlich zum Arzt und sagt, ich lasse mich mal durchchecken, weil wenn ich das rechtzeitig erkenne, dass ich tatsächlich irgendwie vielleicht einen Tumor habe, dann kann man was dagegen machen, was man nicht könnte, wenn man eben keine Ahnung hat, was eigentlich das eigentliche Risiko ist und vielleicht deshalb auch überhaupt nicht zum Arzt gegangen ist.
Und wie sicher sind solche Voraussagen? Also ist das dann ganz konkret oder kann es dann auch noch eine falsche Warnung sein?
Na ja, die allermeisten dieser Assoziationen, die man aus dem Genom ablesen kann, sind einfach Wahrscheinlichkeiten. Also in meinem Fall, ich habe ein doppelt so hohes Risiko an Prostata Krebs zu erkranken wie der Durchschnittsbürger und der Durchschnittsbürger hat ein Risiko von 16 Prozent, sagen wir mal. Also ich habe ein 32 Prozent Risiko, irgendwann in meinem Leben Prostata Krebs zu kriegen. Das ist also alles andere als sicher. Allerdings, ein Drittel Wahrscheinlichkeit ist jetzt schon mal eine Hausnummer, wo man vielleicht sagt, das ignoriert man nicht so leicht. Es gibt aber auch andere Krankheiten, wo dann das Risiko, wenn es sich verdoppelt von 0, 5 Prozent auf 1 Prozent geht, da ist das Verdoppeln dann vielleicht nicht ganz so spannend tatsächlich.
Aber gibt es auch sozusagen ein anderes Extrem, dass man sagt, ok, du kriegst auf jeden Fall Augenkrebs?
Ob man was selbst bekommt? Jein, also gibt es bestimmt auch, aber es gibt, was für viele Leute spannender ist, einfach bist du Überträger von einer Erbkrankheit, also du bist nicht selbst betroffen, weil wenn dann würde das von Anfang an quasi von Geburt an ausgeprägt sein und man würde es sehen, aber du trägst nur eine defekte Kopie, aber wenn du jetzt Kinder zeugen solltest, besteht die Möglichkeit, dass du deinem Kind irgendwie dieses Krankheitsrisiko vererbst, zum einen, bzw. dieses eine Allee und wenn dein Partner das auch hat, dass tatsächlich dieser Gendefekt ausgeprägt sein wird.
Genau dazu würde ich gern was sagen und zwar zum einen habe ich meinen Blogpost von ihm eingelesen, der eben auch das bei 23Me eingeschickt hat, also eine Probe, und dann das wieder bekommen hat und er meinte, er wünschte, er hätte es nicht gemacht, weil er seitdem, also danach, richtig schlecht geschlafen hat und total übrüchrender wurde, weil da doch einige Sachen angesagt wurden, die kommen könnten. Und er sagte so, er hat immer das Gefühl, so ungefähr, er stirbt bald. Also das hat ihn ziemlich mitgenommen, das heißt, man sollte sich vorher genau klar sein, ich meine gut, die haben jetzt diesen Teil wieder rausgenommen, aber trotzdem, soll man sich genau klar sein, ob man das möchte und was das für einen bedeuten kann. Bei mir selbst weiß ich halt zum Beispiel durch gar nicht sowas, sondern in Kindertagen war ich irgendwie allergisch gegen Kuhmilch, ich bin ins Krankenhaus gekommen, die haben irgendwie genauer untersucht und auch ein Gendefekt bei mir festgestellt, der eben auch genau durch sowas kommt, wie Sebastian gesagt hat. Also meine Eltern haben das beide nicht, haben beide einer lehle, ich hatte Pech, ich habe genau die beiden bekommen, aber auch da ist es jetzt wieder, ich habe zwar diesen Gendefekt, der ist aber in einer Ausprägung, die so schwach ist, dass die einzige Konsequenz für mein Leben ist, dass ich nicht körperlich in der Lage bin, Trompeten oder sowas zu spielen. Da kann ich jetzt ganz gut mit leben. Ich weiß aber auch, dass wenn ich zum Beispiel rauchen würde, die Schäden, die ich davon nehme, ein vielfaches höher wären als bei anderen. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich eine gute Information für mich, dass ich weiß, Rauchen wäre für mich, wenn ich das anfange, viel destruktiver als bei anderen. Gleichzeitig heißt das, ich weiß, ich habe diese beiden kaputten Alleele, wenn ich mal Kinder haben möchte, habe ich mich selbst halt auch schon gefragt, will ich meinen Partner vorher testen? Denn diesen Defekt, den ich habe, ich habe den halt in der schwächsten Abstufung, die es gibt. Wenn man den in der stärksten hat, werden die Kinder nicht über ein Jahr. Und auch die anderen hohen Stufen sind dann so eher so, die Kinder werden 10, die Kinder werden 20 und dann ist vorbei. Das heißt, für mich ist es zum einen gut, es zu wissen. Auf der anderen Seite stehe ich vor einer ganz komischen Entscheidung, wenn ich mal Kinder kriege, ob ich meinen Partner testen lassen will. Und was ist das? Vor allem, was mache ich mit der Antwort? Ich meine, wenn es ist, ja, er hat das gar nicht, das Erlehrt. Das heißt, die Kinder können das nicht haben. Die kriegen ja nur eins von mir mit. Man kriegt ja immer von beiden Eltern einen Teil mit. Dann klar, wäre ich beruhigt. Aber was ist, wenn ich mitbekomme, der hat da eins. Dann ist die Chance 50-50, dass das Kind krank ist. Und dann ist wieder die Frage, in welcher Extremvariante hat das das? Das sind halt Sachen, da muss man wirklich... Also da hab ich auch für mich selbst noch keine Antwort gefunden, weil ich das immer nach hinten geschoben hab. Aber das sind Sachen, die machen solche Entscheidungen nicht einfacher.
Da kommen wir jetzt aber direkt zu dem Punkt Ethik in der Bioinformatik. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, das ist tatsächlich ein ganz schwieriges Thema, weil es vielleicht auch Bestrebungen gibt, dass da Krankenkassen dann sagen, so eine Genom-Analyse, die könnte man auch eigentlich mal so bevölkerungsweit machen. Dann legen wir mal aufgrund davon neue Krankenkassensätze vor. Gibt es so eine Bestrebung?
In Deutschland gibt es einfach das Gen-Diagnostik-Gesetz, was zumindest Krankenkassen verbietet, tatsächlich solche Gentests einzufordern. Ich glaube, die Ausnahme davon, vielleicht kann mich weh korrigieren, wenn es falsch ist, sind Lebensversicherungen. Die haben tatsächlich irgendwie noch ein Anrecht darauf, informiert zu werden, wenn man schon einen Gentest hat und man weiß, dass man irgendwelche schlimmen Krankheiten bekommen wird. Dann haben die einen Anrecht darauf, das zu erfahren. Bei Krankenkassen ist tatsächlich momentan verboten, darüber quasi zu diskriminieren. Und ich meine, für Arbeitgeber gilt das Gleiche in Deutschland.
Auch schon ein interessanter Punkt, weil man den Gentest einmal gemacht hat, dann gibt es möglicherweise Leute, die darauf zugreifen können, dürfen, wollen. Das ist tatsächlich die Frage, ob man es tatsächlich macht. Und dann das andere ist natürlich auch so diese persönliche Erfahrung. Will man von jemand fordern, einen Genom im Gentest zu machen? Glaubt ihr, das kommt in Zukunft, dass das so selbstverständlicher wird? Dass man halt denkt, wenn ich mit dir eine langfristige Partnerschaft eingehe, dann guck doch mal bitte nach, was du so an Schäden hast.
Fast tatsächlich. Tatsächlich gab es, glaube ich, mal aus München sogar, irgendwie von der Uni, ein Start-up, das gegründet wurde, was Dating basierend auf Gentests machen wollte. Allerdings nicht, um zu schauen, ob die Kinder Krankheiten haben, sondern ich glaube über Immungene, die dann tatsächlich eher voraussagen, ob man sich gegenseitig riechen kann. Also ob der Geruch des Partners einem zusagt oder nicht.
Aber trotzdem noch die Frage, diese ethischen Überlegungen, spielen die schon eine Rolle? Oder ist Bioinformatik gerade noch so dieses Goldgräberstimmung? Ja, wir werden das Genom sequenzieren und so was. Oder gibt es da auch schon Arbeit zu?
Es gibt Arbeit dazu tatsächlich. Also die Biologie hat sich jetzt in der Vergangenheit insgesamt nicht so mit viel rumbekleckert über Bioethik selbst, muss man ja leider sagen. Nicht nur irgendwie in Deutschland in den 30er und 40er Jahren, sondern auch in anderen Bereichen irgendwie danach. Deshalb ist ziemlich stark ausgeprägte Ethiksysteme irgendwie wenn man mit Menschen forscht und die Bioinformatik ist davon natürlich auch betroffen und der Grund, warum halt menschliche Datensätze oft nicht frei verfügbar sind. Ich glaube, Lisa hat das angesprochen, dass eben das, was sie untersuchen wollte, da sind die Daten nicht frei verfügbar, ist häufig genau aus dem Grund, dass man eben sagt, wir müssen unsere Probanden schützen und deshalb sind diese Daten nicht frei verfügbar.
Wir sind jetzt hierhin gekommen und haben eine Runde unterbrochen, nämlich die zu erfahren, was die Gesprächspartner hier eigentlich, wie sie zur Bioinformatik gekommen sind und was sie da so tun oder getan haben. Carina fehlt da noch. Wie bist du zur Bioinformatik gekommen?
Ja, bei mir war das, dann hab ich überlegt, was ich so studieren will und bin dann irgendwie bei Informatik gelandet, hab dann überlegt, na, nur Informatik. Ich bin so ein Mensch, der kann sich nicht so ewig mit einem Thema beschäftigen. Ich brauch ein bisschen Abwechslung. Hab mir dann irgendwie Medieninformatik, ja, Wirtschaftsinformatik auch angeguckt. Ich kann mich nicht so richtig entscheiden. Dann hab ich irgendwie die Hochschule in St. August hingefunden und festgestellt, super, da muss ich mich erst im vierten Semester für einen Schwerpunkt entscheiden und hab alles, was ich mir so angeguckt habe, als Möglichkeit und hab dann einfach diese Entscheidung nach hinten verschoben. Hab dann da Informatik angefangen zu studieren, hatte dann irgendwann wo die Sachen vorgestellt und hab festgestellt bis dahin, also mir liegt Algorithmik, mir liegt Programmieren. Ja, das kann ich in der Bioinformatik machen, dann nehm ich das. Also es war ziemlich ungeplant, es kam dann spontan. Und dann bin ich da auch direkt so richtig eingestiegen. Das heißt, ich hab dann mein, irgendwie so ein Praxisprojekt, was wir in den Semesterferien machen mussten, dann da gemacht. Und bin am Fraunhofer Institut gelandet, also wirklich in der Forschung in der Abteilung Bioinformatik. Und hab dort halt im Bereich Image-Mining gearbeitet, also gar nicht in der klassischen Bioinformatik. Bin dann im Rahmen meines Studiums auch mal ins Ausland gegangen, nach Kanada, Halifax. Und hab da wirklich mich auf Bioinformatik fokussiert, in dem Semester, wo ich da war. Und da hab ich auch wirklich ein Forschungsprojekt gemacht. Und es gab zwei interessante Sachen. Also die eine interessante Sache war so, ich hatte vorher so einen Einführungskurs Bioinformatik, was es dann halt so an der Uni gibt, in Deutschland gemacht bei einem Informatiklehrer. Und bei diesen ganzen Vergleichen und so gibt es immer zwei Schritte. Das ist eines dieser phylogenetische Baum, von denen wir gerade schon gehört haben. Also da werden die einzelnen Gene, oder Genome oder Snippets, also irgendwie diese Stücke, die ich vergleichen will, sozusagen sortiert schon mal nach Ähnlichkeit. Und danach macht man die eigentlichen Vergleiche. Und der meinte immer, dieses Sortieren in diesen Baum ist total trivial, das machen wir einfach. Aber dieses Vergleichen, das ist das, wo die Komplexität ist. Und da gibt es Algorithmen und da haben wir uns ganz intensiv mit beschäftigt. Und dann bin ich da nach Kanada gekommen und saß, im Endeffekt der gleichen Vorlesung, aber gehalten von Biologen. Und der meinte, naja, also hier diese Bäume machen, sodass man es richtig sortiert. Und so, da ist die ganze Intelligenz. Das ist das Schwierige. Das ist das, wo wir unser Wissen reinstecken. Danach die Vergleiche. Da gibt es hier so eine Software, die heißt Blast. Da kippen wir das rein und dann tut das das. Und wir saßen da so im Moment. Und da habe ich gelernt, dass es beides total komplex ist. Aber je nachdem aus welchem Bereich du kommst, ob du ein Informatiker bist oder ein Biologe, hast du halt einen anderen Fokus und eine andere Sicht da drauf. Und das fand ich schon mal sehr, sehr spannend, weil ich dann einfach gelernt habe, dass man auch in der Uni einfach nicht die Wahrheit lernt. Und dann haben wir dort ein Forschungsprojekt gemacht, was auch sehr spannend war, wofür sich der eine oder andere Zuhörer mit identifizieren kann. Das ist nämlich Grippe. Ich hab mir angeschaut, wie entsteht eigentlich andauernd neue Grippe. Also das Problem, vielleicht muss man mal klären, wie Grippe sich denn so verbreitet. Also ich rede jetzt hier nicht von dieser Kältung mit Husten und Schnuppen, wo alle sagen, ich hab eine Grippe, sondern die echte Grippe, wo man mit Fieber und allem richtig flach liegt. Und das ist ja ein Virus, der in den Körper geht und die Zelle befällt. Und was da passiert ist, dieses Genom tritt, oder dieser Virus kommt in die Zelle und löst sich erstmal auf. Und selbst das Genom zerlegt sich in seine Bestandteile, in acht Gene. Diese Gene schwirren sozusagen in der Zelle rum und irgendwann, wenn die Zelle stirbt, baut sich das wieder zusammen, der Virus. Das heißt, er nimmt dann wieder seine acht Gene und geht weiter. Wenn jetzt jemand schon Grippe hat einer Art, also sagen wir H1N1, das ist so eine Grippe, die schon seit Ewigkeiten existiert. Also eigentlich war die schon mal ausgerottet, aber die Russen waren nicht so vorsichtig im Labor. Jetzt gibt's sie wieder. Oder H5N1, das war halt hier die bekannte Vogelgrippe, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht vertue. Die, sagen wir mal, hat halt zwei davon. Dann passiert es, dass die sich beide auflösen. Und wenn dann die Zelle stirbt, gehen wieder acht Gene, auch je eins von jedem Typ, also es gibt auch verschiedene Typen, zusammen. Und bilden wieder eine neue, sozusagen wieder eine Grippe. Virus, so ein Kleines. Aber wenn da zwei drin waren, nimmt das halt nicht jetzt genau die acht, die vorher zusammengehörten mit, sondern vielleicht eins von dem einen, sieben von dem anderen oder fünf zu drei. Also der mischt sich. Und das, was da rausfällt, kann sein, dass das gar nicht lebensfähig ist, weil die Stücke gar nicht so gut zusammenpassen. Es kann aber auch passieren, dass das lebensfähig ist. Und dann gibt es eigentlich zwei Sachen, die gemessen werden. Das eine ist, wie einfach Leute angesteckt werden und wie pathogen, also wie tödlich eigentlich oder wie stark die Erkrankung ist. Die perfekte Kombination ist der Virus, der sich am Schluss durchsetzt. Deswegen haben wir immer wieder neue Grippewellen. Jedes Jahr muss man sich, wenn man sich impfen geht, neu impfen oder es hilft selbst dann nicht, weil sich das immer weiter verändert. Das Interessante ist, dass es bedeutet, dass jede neue Grippeart genau in einem Menschen entstanden ist. Und man das im Nachhinein nachvollziehen kann auf exakt die Person, wo das herkommt. Das ist ziemlich spannend, weil man einfach sehen kann, wir haben jetzt diesen Grippe-Strang. Die Grippe ist meldepflichtig. Die Ärzte, wenn du da hinkommst, nehmen einen Test und schicken das ein und das wird gemeldet. Dann wissen die, okay, hier ist das entstanden. Dann konnten wir gucken, wo gab es dieser neue, den wir jetzt haben, aus welchen zwei ist der gemischt worden? Oder ist dieser aus zweien gemischt worden? Und wenn ja, aus welchen genau? Da vergleicht man wieder riesen Datenmengen. Und welche Teile wurden getauscht? Also welche Gene wurden getauscht? Das nennt sich Reassortments, also wird so umsortiert. Da habe ich in diesem Forschungsprojekt wirklich neue Reassortments festgestellt. Also ich habe ein riesen Datenset mir runtergeladen. Typisch Bioinformatik heißt, man hat eine Menge Tools, die es gibt, wo man dann die Parameter und so anpasst für sich. Und eine Menge Skripte schreibt, die die ganzen Datenformate umformen, weil die sich alle nicht einigen können, welches Datenformat die benutzen. Ich glaube, das kennt jeder von euch. Jeder Bioinformatiker schreibt vor allem Skripte, die sowas machen. Und ja, das war dann so mein Forschungsergebnis, war dann eine Abhandlung und eine Vorstellung von irgendwie, ich glaube, fünf oder sechs neuen Reassortments, die bis dato auch keiner gefunden hatte. Wo ich sagen konnte, okay, diese Grippestränge, die wir kennen, sind genau an dieser Stelle dort passiert. Und dann sprang so in mir auf der einen Seite der Forschern und auf der anderen Seite der Datenschützer. Ich dachte, boah, wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wie diese Leute gereist sind und wo die sich aufgehalten haben, dann könnte ich genau sehen, wie exakt diese Grippe wirklich von Person zu Person gesprungen ist und das ganz genau nachvollziehen. Und der Datenschützer in mir hat natürlich geschrien, so, oh mein Gott, das ist komplette Überwachung, die wir brauchen. Der Forscher dachte, boah, wenn ich das bloß hätte, das wär so geil, ich könnte so viel rausfinden. Und das ist auch so ein ganz großes Dilemma, was man hat. Weil natürlich mir auf der anderen Seite klar ist, würden wir diese Daten erheben, selbst mit den besten Intentionen. Sie würden auf der fatalste Weise genutzt werden können und es würde natürlich passieren, dass Daten, die erhoben sind, werden genutzt für alles. Und das fand ich einen sehr interessanten Konflikt, in den man da einfach kommt. Und wo ich immer so ein bisschen auch merkte, die Biologen-Kollegen, die sich noch nicht so mit der Informatik und dem Datenschutz auseinandergesetzt hatten, waren teilweise ein bisschen, hatten halt nicht diese Bedenken, die auf der anderen Seite standen, sondern dachten nur, wir brauchen diese Daten.
Hättest du dir wieder stehen können, wenn jemand auf dem Silberwetter-Tablett gesagt hätte, so hier, guck mal, da sind die Daten, willst du vielleicht mal kurz reingucken?
Naja, also ich könnte dir wieder stehen, weil ich sozusagen schon verurteilen würde, das Erfassen, weil das Erfassen dieser Daten ist halt nichts Triviales. Hier geht es nicht um irgendwelche Zuordnungen oder so, sondern es geht darum, dass man eine totale Überwachung der Reisebewegung aller Personen bräuchte auf dieser Welt und mit wem die auch interagieren, damit man wüsste, wo, wie, was entstanden ist. Das sind einfach Dinge, die gehen viel zu weit in die Privatsphäre, als dass man das irgendwie gut heißen könnte. Aber es gab schon interessante Projekte auch so. Also gerade bei älteren Datensätzen, wo die Leute noch nicht so viel gereist sind, also vor einigen Jahrzehnten schon, gibt es einfach schöne Overlays für Google Earth, wo man dann sieht, wie eben so aus Asien so langsam die Grippe rüber wandert. Und da gibt es dann auch etwas neuere Sätze, wo man einfach sieht, wie extrem das beschleunigt ist und auch Sprünge hat von üblichen Reisen. Wo man plötzlich sieht, die Grippe hat einen halben Kontinent innerhalb von ein paar Tagen übersprungen, weil irgendjemand krank gereist ist und dann die Nächsten wieder infiziert hat. Auch jetzt kann man da schon einiges sehen, was ganz schön beeindruckend ist. Und vorhin hatte ich die Geschichte schon erzählt und da war direkt die Assoziation zu diesem Spiel, was es gibt. Genau, da wird ja genau so was simuliert. Und da geht es eben auch um, dass man einen Virus entwickelt. Ich habe es gar nicht gespielt, aber sagt mir, wenn ich was falsch sage. Aber da geht es ja auch darum, dass man einen Virus entwickelt, der genau diese Eigenschaften hat, zwischen dem, dass er sich gut weiterverbreitet und dann die Leute in der richtigen Zeit sterben. Weil wenn die Leute zu schnell wegsterben, also krank werden, also infiziert sind, sofort krank sind, sofort sterben, sonst werden keine neuen Leute infiziert.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr, sehr großartiges Spiel. Man fängt mit dem Virus an und kann dann immer auswählen, soll er ansteckender sein, soll er Resistenzen entwickeln, wie hoch soll die Mortalitätsrate sein. Kann ich ihm natürlich nur empfehlen.
Das Krasse, was viele nicht wissen, also bei der Grippe, dieses H1N1 oder H2N3, was man so gehört hat, das ist H und N, das sind zwei Buchstaben, die jetzt für den Namen identifizieren, welches Gen es ist in diesem Genom. Und zwar sind das die zwei, die die Oberfläche beschreiben. Nur wenn sich die Oberfläche verändert, ist das auch eine Veränderung für unser Immunsystem. Und wir erkennen es plötzlich nicht mehr, weil es anders aussieht. Deswegen werden diese Zahlen genommen zum Identifizieren. Weil natürlich nur wenn sich die Oberfläche nicht in etwas verändert, reagiert plötzlich das Immunsystem da nicht drauf. Und was natürlich alle dann so sich gefragt haben, welche Mischungen kannst du so geben, die dann besonders gefährlich wären? Dann ist wirklich ein Wissenschaftler im Labor hingegangen und hat so ein bisschen den bösen, verrückten Wissenschaftler gespielt. Der hat nämlich alle Formen, die bekannt sind schon, einmal durchkombiniert und dann geguckt an Tierchen, wie dann jetzt plötzlich die Tierchen schnell sterben und die Ansteckungen...
Hat er einen Supergrippevirus entwickelt?
Also der hat eigentlich genau Plague gespielt, nur in echt. Und hat dann auch rausgefunden, welcher der nächste wäre, der wie die spanische Grippe im Ersten Weltkrieg, die über zwei Drittel der Bevölkerung infiziert hat, denn die nächste große Gefahr wäre. Wo ich mir auch dachte, nach dem Vorfall mit den Russen, die nicht auf ihr Zeug aufgepasst haben, fand ich das ein bisschen gruselig, aber wir hatten Glück. Aber das existiert immer noch in einem Schrank, in einem Labor. Weil man das auch braucht, um dann schnell einen Impfstoff entwickeln zu können, wenn das ausbricht.
Puh, dank Bioinformatik wurde schon die Supergrippe entwickelt. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Um das zu verdauen, haben wir jetzt eine kleine Musik. Dann geht es in die letzte halbe Stunde. Chaosradio 211 aus der Marienstraße 11 im Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Heute zum Thema Bioinformatik mit Lisa. Mit Carina. Mit Carina.
Hallo.
Und Bastian. Hi. Ah, sehr schön, alle noch da. Aber ihr seid vielleicht schon abgeschreckt, denn wir haben in den letzten anderthalb Stunden viel gelernt, nämlich also Bioinformatik ist, ich drücke es mal despektierlich aus, vor allen Dingen langweiliges Arbeiten mit Algorithmen. Ausgeliefert ist man der Industrie, die möglichst neues Viagra erfinden will und außerdem ermöglicht es datenschutzbedenkliche Forschung am menschlichen Genom und führt dazu, dass Leute super grippivieren entwickeln.
Das waren die Biologen, also momentan, so geht es nicht.
Natürlich waren es die Biologen möglicherweise, aber wir haben ja gelernt, dass sozusagen durch die Faltungen von Genomen und die Computerausrechnung der Formen, man viel leichter so eine Dinge machen kann als vorher, weil die Informatiker durch voll dynamische Algorithmen dafür sorgt, dass diese ganzen Proteste optimiert werden.
Ne, ne, ne, also das mit dem Grippivirus, das war kombinatorisch, das kann man mit einem Taschenrechner machen.
Jaja, das hätte ich jetzt anstelle eines Bioinformatikers auch gesagt. Wir wollen die letzte verbleibende Zeit dafür nutzen, um mal zu sagen, falls Leute, die jetzt trotz dieser Horrormeldungen nicht abgeschreckt wurden, denken so, ja Bioinformatik vielleicht ein ganz interessantes Ding, wo andere Knüpfungspunkte für die wären. Und da würde ich jetzt erstens gerne die Frage stellen, ist das denn was, wo man sich nur für interessieren sollte, wenn man das jetzt irgendwie studieren will oder das wirklich ernsthaft betreiben will, oder ist das tatsächlich auch was, was man so als Neben-Hobby noch betreiben kann?
Neben-Hobby, vielleicht können wir auch noch, das ist jetzt ein bisschen kurz gekommen, tatsächliche lebensnahe Beispiele und Anwendungen.
Da habe ich die ganze Zeit nach gefragt und du hast immer gesagt, nein, man kann sich keine grünen Fingernägel wachsen lassen.
Okay, ich bin nicht ganz sicher, was du mit den grünen Fingernägeln hast, aber das ist wieder Biologie. Also wenn es denn keine Bits mehr sind, dann ist das Biologie. Aber ich glaube, da gab es sogar schon mal Bestrebungen Bierbrauen. Und zwar ging es da konkret um die Berliner Weiße, die ursprüngliche alte und Ähnliches mit Weinherstellung. Und sehr viele andere Lebensmittelprozesse, wo Mikroorganismen daran beteiligt sind. Da sind die Arten von Mikroorganismen tatsächlich wichtig. Also die original Berliner Weiße braucht eigentlich genau diesen Stamm von Milchsäurebakterien, der da ursprünglich benutzt wurde. Und ich weiß nicht, ob der Mensch, der sich damit beschäftigt hat, das verfolgt hat, aber man könnte natürlich auch sequenzieren und gucken. Also so alte, nicht mehr so richtig wiederzubelebende Milchsäurebakterien aus alten Berliner Weißflaschen, die jetzt schon so 100 Jahre alt sind oder so, sequenzieren und gucken, inwiefern die sich von den entsprechenden Kulturen, die man heute noch so bekommt, unterscheiden. Ob man da irgendwo einen möglichst nah dran Stamm herbekommt. Ähnlich ist halt bei Sachen wie Käse, Kombucha, solche Geschichten. Also lebensmitteltechnisch tunen und untersuchen für die Leute, die sich furchtbar gerne mit Lebensmitteln beschäftigen. Das nächste ist genau das andere Ende. Alle reden gerne über Kacke. Ja, ist ein wichtiger Forschungszweig. Mikrobiomen. Also in unserem Verdauungstrakt leben viele, viele Mikroorganismen. Die sind auch wichtig. Es gibt sehr viel Forschung, sehr viel Vermutung drüber, dass welche Mikroorganismen da genau leben, einen starken Einfluss auf die Gesundheit, auf so etwas wie Übergewicht, Untergewicht, möglicherweise sogar Laktoseintoleranz, lauter so Geschichten haben. Da gibt es, glaube ich, schon einige Bestrebungen von Leuten, die das jetzt einfach für sich wissen wollen, ob vielleicht einfach ihr Mikrobiom daran schuld ist, dass sie übergewichtig sind, ob man das vielleicht ändern kann, solche Geschichten. Da regelmäßig immer mal Abstriche machen, das sequenzieren lassen und gucken, wenn sie jetzt vier Wochen lang völlig auf Zucker verzichtet haben, ob sich das Mikrobiom dann verändert hat. Ich glaube, Bastian, du hattest doch mal irgendwie so Mikrobiom-Sequenzen da auswerten gemacht, oder?
Ja, genau. Es gibt ähnlich wie 23andMe, die einem das eigene Genom sequenzieren. Auch, ich glaube, U-Biome heißt die Firma, kommt auch aus den USA, denen man dann lustig seine Mikrobiom-Samples schicken kann. Also tatsächlich irgendwie nicht nur aus dem Magen-Darm-Bereich, sondern auch aus dem Mund und irgendwie, was auf der Haut so wächst. Und dann kann man denen, wenn man möchte, eben regelmäßig Proben schicken und kann dann schauen, wie sich über die Zeit die Bakterien, der Bakterienbewuchs auf und im Körper sich verändert. Das klingt echt fies. Man muss auch sagen, dass irgendwie, was ganz spannend ist, das steckt noch ziemlich in den Kinderschuhen. Und das ist relativ viel glaskuglesen bislang noch, gerade mit diesem Mikrobiomzeug. Also natürlich, wenn man einfach zweimal einen Abstrich nimmt, wird man eigentlich immer was anderes finden. Und inwieweit das biologisch relevant ist oder einfach ein Artifakt davon, dass man zwei Abstriche gemacht hat, statt nur einem, ist in vielen Punkten, glaube ich, noch fragwürdig.
Aber schon halt irgendwie interessant und mit Potenzial für Dinge.
Genau, es ist auf jeden Fall interessant. Und ich glaube, wenn man für diese zufälligen Faktoren irgendwann mal ganz gut korrigieren kann, auch sicherlich sehr spannend. Bislang sollte man vielleicht nicht blind diesen Ergebnissen immer vertrauen. Also wenn man dann drei Wochen auf Zucker verzichtet hat und am Ende der drei Wochen sieht man auf einmal andere Bakterien, ob das zwingend damit zusammenhängt, dass man auf Zucker verzichtet hat. Wer weiß.
Ihr habt ja alle mal damit angefangen.
Ja, also wie gesagt, so eine Möglichkeit ist so in die Richtung zu gehen, was ich in meinem Forschungsprojekt gemacht habe. Also diese Daten sind halt frei verfügbar. Es gibt da von NCBI eine große Datenbank. Da kann man sich verschiedenste Sachen runterladen und einfach mal gucken. Also ich fand halt was bei Grippe total spannend, weil es eigentlich recht gut dokumentiert ist, wie man da vorzugehen hat. Die Tools sind auch alle frei verfügbar. Das ist jetzt nichts, was man irgendwie nicht drankommt. Sie sind sogar oft übers Web ansteuerbar. Das heißt, man muss das gar nicht lokal bei sich rechnen, sondern man schickt ihnen die Daten und kriegt dann irgendwann eine Mail, so wir sind jetzt fertig mit Rechnen. Für die ganz großen Datenmengen klappt das nicht, aber für die kleinen ersten Experimente schon ganz gut. Und dann kann man einfach so ein bisschen mal gucken, wie hängen denn Gene zusammen, wo gibt es Unterschiede? Und wie gesagt, man guckt sich halt gar nicht unbedingt ein ganzes Gen an, sondern nur bestimmte Bereiche, die interessant sind. Da gibt es dann auch diese Ausschnitte schon fertig, in wirklich tausenden Varianten. Man kann einfach mal gucken, wo sind Unterschiede? Wo ist alles bei wirklich Hunderten identisch? Oder plötzlich hat man einen Ausreißer und kann man sich den genauer angucken, wo kommt der her?
Gibt es auch sozusagen so Tutorial-Aufgaben, wo man quasi sagen kann, hier versuch doch mal das und das, und dann müsstest du das Ergebnis bekommen.
Ja, es gibt eine sehr schöne Plattform namens Rosalind, was einfach ein interaktives Programmiertutorial für Bioinformatik-Aufgaben ist.
Das ist sehr schick gemacht. Wer das Projekt Euler kennt, was eher aus der reinen Informatik kommt, also das sind Mathematik-Informatik-Aufgaben bei Projekt Euler, gibt es eben mit Rosalind auch für die Bioinformatik, wo man eigentlich fast kein Vorwissen in der Biologie braucht und auch fürs Programmieren fängt das relativ einfach an. Also wenn man sich mal tatsächlich von ganz Grund auf einarbeiten will, ist das ein ganz guter Start.
Und ich glaube auch, wenn man aus der Informatik kommt, kann man auch tatsächlich über Bücher einsteigen. Also ich hab eine Kanten, die hat sich auf ein Jobinterview vorbereitet und ist dann quasi in ein Bioinformatikproblem reingefallen und hat sich ein Buch gekauft, das heißt Algorithms and Strings, Trees and Sequences von Dan Gasfield. Und da geht es um reine Algorithmik ohne allzu längliche Bioerklärungen, würde ich sagen. Und er meinte, er konnte das auch so lesen und fand es so spannend, dass er es komplett durchgearbeitet hat.
Vorhin hat einer von euch noch etwas über Metagenomik oder so ähnlich gesagt. Es sollte noch ein Punkt sein, den wir unbedingt erwähnen sollten. Noch mehr? Dann müssen wir uns aber langsam beeilen.
Ein Buch, was ich noch prima fand zum Einstieg für Informatik ist Introduction to Computational Genomics von Christian Nini, was so ein bisschen geschichtenmäßig aufgebaut ist. Jedes Kapitel hat eine Geschichte, wie viel Neandertaler steckt eigentlich in uns und wie funktioniert eigentlich ein Zirkadianer Rhythmen. Und in jedem Kapitel durcharbeitet, wie man da mit Methoden der Bioinformatik rangehen würde. Das ist sehr hübsch gemacht und es liest sich auch gut weg. Sonst noch Coursera hat ein paar sehr schöne Bioinformatik Kurse. Pavel Pevtsna.
Was ist Coursera? Was ist das?
Coursera ist eine großartige Plattform für Uni-Kurse im Internet. Also wirklich mit Video Lectures und wöchentlichen Übungsaufgaben und Praktika und Foren, wo man sich mit anderen Studenten austauschen kann. Super, ganz großartig. Und man kann die Videos auf doppelte Geschwindigkeit stellen.
Alright, noch mehr?
Also es gibt auch noch ein paar, ich weiß gar nicht, hier in Berlin bin ich gar nicht so bewandert, aber es gibt halt auch ein paar Hacker-Spaces, die sich mit diesen ganzen Thematiken beschäftigen. Also ich war jetzt vor kurzem in Prag und bin da in ein Hacker-Space gelaufen, weil ich das irgendwie in jeder Stadt, wo ich zu Besuch bin, gerne mal mache. Und die hatten auch einen ganzen Biohack-Bereich im Keller irgendwie und es war auch total spannend, was die da gemacht haben. Das war auch so, ja manches ging es echt in chemische, da haben sie irgendwie aus Chili-Pulver, das, wie heißt das, was das so scharf macht? Genau, das haben sie versucht da raus zu extrahieren. Und also die verschiedensten Sachen hatten die da, wo die einfach so von eher Chemielevel bis eben wirklich in die Bioinformatik gegangen sind, das war schon sehr spannend. Da muss man halt auch einfach mal gucken, was es so gibt.
Fahrt nach Prag, trinkt gutes Bier und geht in den Biohackspace. Okay, ich würde zum Abschluss noch gerne von jedem von euch noch so eine typische Abschlussfrage noch mal stellen, und zwar dieses, was ihr glaubt, was das nächste große Ding in der Bioinformatik ist, Bastian?
Das nächste große Ding in der Bioinformatik, ich glaube, weil ich viel dieses ganze Puzzlen von unbekannten Organismen mache, ist, dass wir endlich längere Wörter lesen können. Momentan haben wir das Problem, dass unsere Maschinen, mit denen wir Genome versuchen, auszulesen, vielleicht die, die weit verbreitet sind, schaffen es, 250 Zeichen am Stück zu lesen, und dann hört das Wort auf. Und aus 250 zeichenlangen Worten dann die 3 Milliarden wieder zusammen zu puzzeln, ist echt doof. Und es gibt mittlerweile Sequenziermaschinen, die einfach winzig sind und super lange Wörter lesen können. Also Oxford Nanopore zum Beispiel ist eine Technik, die ist USB Memory Stick groß, wird auch über USB einfach an den Laptop angeschlossen und man kann sequenzieren und kriegt dann 130.000 zeichnelange Worte, die das ganze Puzzlen viel einfacher machen und dass man es einfach USB Stick groß in seinen Rechner anschließt. Man kann auf einmal überall sequenzieren. Also wenn man sagt, man geht in den Dschungel und sammelt als Biologe Proben im Feld, kann man auch das Sequenzieren gleich im Feld machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das nächste große Ding ist, aber es ist vielleicht mein nächstes große Ding. Metagenomik, ziemlich spannende, ist auch ein bisschen ein Buzzword, gebe ich dazu. Grundproblem ist, klassisch in der Mikrobiologie studiert man Organismen, indem man sie, ob Petrischeien oder sonst was, in Kultur anzüchtet. Das Problem ist, dass nur sehr wenige Organismen da tatsächlich so drauf wachsen. Viele Mikroorganismen wachsen eigentlich nur in ihrer Umgebung, in Kollektiven mit anderen Mikroorganismen. Das heißt, man kann die nicht so richtig gut studieren. Aber jetzt können wir ja alles sequenzieren und können ganze Kollektive von Mikroorganismen, die voneinander abhängig sind und ohne einander gar nicht leben können, untersuchen, unterforschen und gucken, wie die zusammenarbeiten. Und das finde ich immer gespannt.
Ja, ich würde mich da anschließen. Metagenomik ist auf jeden Fall ein großes Ding. Und ich glaube, dass wir in Daten ertrinken werden. Also ich glaube, das passiert schon, dadurch, dass wir halt viel schneller sequenzieren können und mehr sequenzieren können und es auch günstiger wird. Es gab dann solche Projekte wie dieses 1000 Genomes Project, wo die 1000 Genome sequenziert haben, aber 1000 Menschen mit Genome. Genau.
Nicht 1000 Bakterien, sondern 1000 Menschen mit Genome.
Das sind super viele Daten. Und die Frage ist, wer soll die alle verarbeiten? Und das ist meine große Frage an die Zukunft der Bioinformatik, würde ich sagen. Wie gehen wir mit diesen großen Datenmengen um? Da gibt es auch dieses tolle Buzzword Big Data. Aber wer soll das eigentlich alles verarbeiten? Also es fällt jetzt halt viel schneller an, als man es analysieren kann.
Vielleicht neue Maschinen, vielleicht noch eine Hame von Bioinformatikern.
Ja, für mich ist so das nächste große Ding, auf das ich gespannt bin, vor allem personalisierte Medizin. Also gibt es jetzt schon im Kleinen, dass wirklich genau auf die Hygiene geguckt wird von irgendwie Tumoren oder so, das sequenziert wird. Da hatte Lisa von, glaube ich, auch was kurz zu gesagt. Also als wir uns unterhalten haben. Das finde ich total spannend, wo einfach geguckt wird, was liegt denn da genau vor, um die Diagnostik noch genau zu machen und dann eben auch die ganz exakte Therapie dafür zu finden. Zum Beispiel.
Sehr schön. Bastian, Carina, Linse und Lisa für einen kleinen zweistündigen Einstück in die Bioinformatik. Vielen Dank. Das war auf jeden Fall sehr spannend und auch ein bisschen gruselig, wie ich finde. Und ich bin gespannt, was ihr davon haltet. Könnt ihr gerne noch in die Kommentare schreiben unter chaosradio.ccc.de, wo dann auch demnächst der Podcast dieser Sendung erscheinen wird. Wir machen jetzt hier noch, bevor wir ganz verschwinden. Und ich wünsche euch einen guten Abend und noch einen kleinen Werbeblock. Denn es ist jetzt so Anfang des Jahres die Zeit, wo die ganzen tausend Millionen Konferenzen und Veranstaltungen an den Start kommen. Da dürfen wir ganz herzlich vom Chaos Computer Club Berlin den Herrn Erdgeist begrüßen, der gerade hierher wandelt. Aua und mich tritt an den Mikrofon. Und Monique, in ihrer Funktion, weiß ich gar nicht. Ich kenne sie von den Freifunkern, aber vielleicht noch auch in einer anderen Funktion hier.
Ja, doch schon Freifunker und Mitglied im Förderverein Freien Netzwerke.
Sehr gut, so ihr habt jetzt irgendwie noch, ihr habt nur noch ein paar Minuten Zeit, aber wollt ungefähr 50.000 Veranstaltungen dem geneigten Hörer ans Herz legen. Wir fangen an mit Hass.
Es sind nur sieben. Nein, wir fangen an mit dem Kongress der Möglichkeiten. Das ist koorganisiert vom Hate-Magazin und vom Chaos Computer Club. Das ist vom 30. April bis zum 10. Mai. Obwohl so richtig los geht es dann so am 8. 9. 10. wenn da die Workshops und Diskussionsrunden, Performances sind. In dieser Konferenz geht es darum, für Künstler und Menschen, die die Welt verändern wollen, in der aktuellen, durch technisierten und überwachtenden Gesellschaft noch Lebensräume zu finden. Finde ich toll spannend. Das ist in Betanien, in Berlin. Und am 30. ist die Vernissage.
Das war quasi heute.
Du hast recht, heute war oder ist die Vernissage. Nächster Termin ist die Republika, 5. bis 7. Mai. So wie die Blogosphäre, Masse, 450 Speaker, 300 Stunden pro Gramm, 6000 Teilnehmer. Und weiß nicht, ob man viel über die Republika noch erzählen muss. In Wirklichkeit trifft man sich einfach im großen Hof zum Bier.
Manche sagen so, manche sagen so. Astro Alex soll da sein, was ich sehr spannend finde.
Ja, diverse spannende Speaker sind da, aber die werden ja auch gestreamt. Und Tickets kann man sich den Eintrittspreis sparen, wenn man eine Schicht dort engelt. Ansonsten sind es 99 Euro für Studenten oder 99 Euro regulär. Nächste Veranstaltung ist vom 7. bis 10. Mai die KryptoCon in Leipzig. Da macht das Sublab unter dem Motto alles Blümchenwiese. Eine Konferenz, wo es darum geht, um praktische Verschlüsselung und wie Politik und Gesellschaft das Recht darauf einfließen zu nehmen. Und welche Freiräume man als Nörd hat, um anderen Menschen Kryptographie beizubringen. Aber es ist halt auch an Autonormalbürger gerichtet. Da hat ein gewisser Herr Erdgeist zuhört aufgeschrieben. Ja, ich wurde zur Kinoat geladen. Am 7. ist dann noch so ein Sozialprogramm. Und die Vorträge finden dann auch am Wochenende statt. Also am 9. und 10. Mai.
Man kann quasi durchgehend sich auf Konferenzen rumtreiben. Dann ist aber erst mal vier Tage Pause. Und dann beginnt am 14. Mai die Open-Tech-Summit in Berlin. Worum geht es da?
Ja, die Open-Tech-Summit dreht sich um alle möglichen Open-Everything-Themen. Die Idee ist, verschiedene Gruppen zusammenzubringen. Aus den Bereichen Open-Hardware, Free-Software, Libre-Graphics, aber auch Themen wie Internet und Gesellschaft anzusprechen, Lizenzen, Patente und so weiter. Wir haben ein paar ganz spannende Gäste. Mitch Altman wird einen Löt-Workshop beispielsweise bei uns geben. Oder Andi wird eine Strickmaschine live hacken. Freifunker werden Flasher-Workshops oder Router flaschen. Ganz viele bunte Vorträge wird es geben. Und wenn ihr jetzt auf die opentechsummit.net geht und dort ein Ticket kaufen möchtet, könnt ihr auch einfach nichts bezahlen und ein Code Chaosradio eingeben. Und dann gibt es ein paar Freitickets hier.
Gilt das auch für die Leute, die den Podcast noch hören?
Auch.
Wo ist das nochmal?
Das ist in der Kalkscheune in Berlin. Und los geht's am 14. Mai um 10 Uhr. Bis ungefähr 17.30 Uhr werden so Vorträge-Workshops sein. Und abends gibt es noch die Himmelfahrts-Open-Tech-Summit-Lounge mit ein bisschen Musik.
Und dann noch danach gleich das Wireless-Community-Vigent.
Genau. Das gibt es im Anschluss in der Seabase. Da treffen sich wie schon seit gefühlten 100 Jahren die Freifunker aus ganz Deutschland mit ihren internationalen Gästen. Ja und wie immer ist da das Motto hacken, grillen, chillen. Und wenig später im August.
Was geht dann los?
Da geht es nochmal weiter mit den Violet Communities. Das treffen ja europäische Violet Communities. Das ist sogenannte Battle Mesh. Da treten also Protokolle und Firmware gegeneinander an. Und ja, das ist dieses Jahr in Slowenien, in Maribor, vom 3. bis zum 9. August.
Und dann bleibt natürlich noch...
Dann geht es danach direkt zum?
Zum Camp. Dieses Jahr ist Camp und dieses Jahr haben wir eine total geile Location, habe ich auf dem Kongress schon erzählt. So eine ehemalige Ziegelei, die jetzt zur Konferenz-Area ausgebaut worden ist. Und da gibt es so, naja, Baggaseen würde man sagen, da ist irgendwie Granate in der Nier. Also man kann planschen. Da gibt es so 3 Sienenzonen, damit spielen, so eine Zuganlage, eine Lokomotive. Und es werden 2 Vortragszelte aufgebaut, wie man vom Camp halt kennt. Also nicht so dringend durchgeplant wie auf dem Kongress. Aber da gibt es Vortragsprogramm, auch ein paar spannende Vorträge. Und einer der bei mir wichtigsten Tracks ist, dass es diesmal einen Philosophietrack gibt, der sich sehr aggressiv und aktiv mit der Fehlerkultur der Nerds auseinandersetzen soll. Wie man damit umgeht, dass Leute natürlich Fehler machen. Wie man die Leute dann darauf drängt, irgendwie mit den Fehlern so offen umzugehen, dass sie sich nicht blamieren oder es gar nicht nach draußen bringen. Weil auch andere Leute können natürlich von Fehlern lernen. Und ich denke, die Hacker-Szene kann da von einer neuen Fehlerkultur nur profitieren.
Fehler machen wir im Chaos Communication Camp in Ziegelpark im Mildenberg im August. Ah ja, Fehler machen kann man auch bei der Republika.
Das ist Datum, noch eine 13. bis 17. August dieses Jahres.
Wir haben viel zu lange gebraucht. Auch das ist ein Fehler in dieser Matrix, in dieser Sendung. Vielen Dank nochmal allen Beteiligten. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß. Hört den Podcast, kommentiert, empfehlt uns weiter. Und ansonsten hören wir uns bald wieder. Mir bleibt immer noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.